[Music]
i still water what you doing
hello carl
i'm just about to have my lunch would
you like to join me
okay
what are you having all of my favorite
things
this is called a bento
what's that
it's called persimmon have you ever
tried them
no are they good oh
i like them very much
but everyone likes things differently
what happens if i don't like them
it can be fun to try new things
even if in the end we don't enjoy them
if you don't like them then you'll know
okay i'll try some persimmon
would you like chopsticks
sure
how do they work here i know a trick
they're like little pinchy fingers
um
it's a little bit crunchy like an apple
and sweet i like it
would you like to try something else
i like to try everything
wonderful
this is seaweed you mean from the ocean
yes from the ocean
it's slippery and crunchy at the same
time
that is lotus root
it doesn't taste like anything
is this a carrot it's called gobo or
burdock root
well
it doesn't taste like a carrot it's
salty
that's ube purple sweet potato
it tastes like a potato but sweet komai
spinach with sesame
this tastes way better than regular
spinach
tofu
i've heard of tofu it's squishy i like
it
is that spaghetti
those are soba noodles made from
buckwheat you dip and slurp
it's cold
and chewy
ah
you saved omaboshi for last
salted plums
they're an acquired taste but i'm proud
of you for trying
i'm proud of me too i'm going to try new
things all the time now
i might find a new favorite food like
persimmons
do you have any more
[Music]
i do indeed
[Music]
you